janet thank you florida has now
surpassed new york as the state with the
second
largest number of coronavirus cases it's
also one of the many states where
testing is a major issue
the u.s now tests an average of roughly
850
000 people a day but some experts
estimate that that number should be
around
4 million our lead national
correspondent david begno joins us from
florida david
is the state able to keep up with the
urgent need for tests there
as much as they'd like to that's why the
feds have stepped in the feds opened up
five surge sites as they're known here
in south florida
and the idea is this one for example
where we are you drive up they give you
the swap you stick it in your nose and
swab yourself
then they're going to send it off to a
private lab in kentucky
they're bypassing the lab core and quest
folks who are taking
seven to ten days in some cases to get
results back and the hope is
in this case you're going to get it back
faster that's the hope
i'm never going to be happy until
we have uh this under control
this is admiral brett gerard he is the
white house coronavirus task force
member who is in charge of testing
he says the average wait time for test
results is between four and seven
days and he acknowledges that is just
too long
we have enough tests right now if we use
them in the right way to achieve the
goals that we need to achieve
some testing sites around the country
are still struggling to meet the demand
while some labs have taken more than two
weeks to provide results
in new mexico the governor who is a
democrat michelle lujan grisham
has placed much of the blame on the
federal government there is no national
strategy
i still spend most of my days chasing
testing supplies for our state
maryland's governor is a republican
larry hogan he's calling for more
federal assistance
for the private testing labs it's
starting to feel
like it did back in march and april
where everybody was overwhelmed
take a listen to dr ashish jaw he's the
director of harvard's global health
institute
we have not enough staff to run a lot of
these tests we're running out of swabs
again
if the federal government back in
february or march had decided to take
testing
seriously we would have built up
adequate testing supplies
katie evans says her husband kevin ended
up at a delaware hospital with the virus
six days after he was tested but on the
same day he was admitted to the hospital
katie got a call from state officials
katie says the results for kevin
and one of her daughters were part of a
group of 12 tests
that had been mistakingly labeled as
negative
had the hospital not reread his results
i would have received a phone call
saying that he was negative i mean who
knows what would have happened then it
could have been so so much worse
what a story good news is kevin is out
of the hospital and at home resting this
morning he's doing much better
listen the vice president mike pence is
coming here to south florida miami
specifically
because there's a brand new vaccine
trial that kicks off today in
combination with the national institutes
of health
and the drug company moderna there will
be 87 sites
around the country 30 000 people who are
participating in a vaccine
trial again that gets started today gail
and we just found out the first
dose was administered in savannah
georgia
this morning
yeah we need some good news this morning
david i'm so glad kevin's story had a
good ending as i was watching i was
thinking oh oh
this can't end well but i'm glad it did
and we just can't seem to get the
testing right
still so much more work to be done david
begnell always good to see